Сьогодні у лейпцизьких хірургів -
непросте хірургічне втручання.
Операція на мозку. Приблизна тривалість -
чотири години.
Пацієнтка поскаржилася на вади зору та втому.
На томографії побачили пухлину в задній частині мозку.
Хірург працює руками. Але техніка стає
для нього дедалі незаміннішою.
Комп‘ютери надають йому інформацію –
про відповідний ареал мозку, про стан пацієнтки.
Це так званий ультразвуковий подрібнювач.
У ньому за допомогою ультразвуку
подрібнюється волокно.
Операція пройшла вдало,
команда зітхає з полегшенням.
Хірург також задоволений,
що обійшовся без комп»ютерного управління пінцетом.
Прилад про всяк випадок стоїть в операційній.
Юрґен Майксенберґер
ініціював дослідний проект у лейпцизькій клініці.
Це експериментальна операційна –
тут зароджується комп»ютеризована хірургія.
А Юрґен Майксенберґер ділиться практичним досвідом.
Мета проекту – тісно скоординувати
дії людини і комп»ютера, а також
зробити можливим використання операційних приладів
різноманітних виробників.
Щоб оператор-хірург міг паралельно керувати усіма інструментами,
потрібними під час операції.
До команди належать 30 інженерів-програмістів.
Держава співфінансує проект.
Виробники медичного обладнання також матимуть
від цього зиск.
Ми розробляємо ці стандарти спільно з промисловістю. І це доцільно,
адже врешті з‘являється відкритий стандарт, який кожен виробник
може застосувати у себе.
На цей сенсорний екран інженери виводять дані
усіх приладів. У цьому експерименті прилади
комунікують між собою.
Я вважаю, що майбутнє операційної техніки – за комп"ютеризацією.
Сьогодні ми бачимо, що такі прилади
не підтримуються відповідним програмним забезпеченням.
І що багато медичних приладів ще не на такому
високому рівні, як у інших галузях промисловості.
У наступні роки, гадаю, у цьому напрямку буде дедалі
більший розвиток.
Розумні програми будуть супроводжувати хірургів,
полегшувати їм роботу.
Приміром, ось такі роботи, що подаватимуть пінцети
на складних операціях на мозку.